Isis will survive its losses in Iraq and
Syria
it is reestablishing a haven in Libya as
a base for coordinating attacks in
Europe and operations across Africa Isis
operates freely in Libya's interior with
access to lucrative smuggling and human
trafficking networks the threat from
Isis in Libya to Europe and eventually
the United States will only grow as Isis
shifts from Iraq and Syria and Isis unit
in Libya facilitated the may 2017
Manchester bombing Isis has also
challenged Tunisia the lone Arab Spring
success with attacks from Libya the
impact of military operations against
Isis has been fleeting it's recovering
from the loss of cert its stronghold on
the Libyan coast to us-backed forces in
late 2016 the West cannot win against
Isis without defeating it in Libya
success in Libya requires ending its
civil war which is allowed Isis and
other terrorist groups including
al-qaeda to use the country as a base
for planning and conducting attacks what
do you think is the best way to stop
Isis and al-qaeda let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI